the OverWatch League the highest level
of competitive play is dead the esport
as we once knew it is basically
non-existent now that being said
OverWatch the game is in a really good
place right now there are updates coming
down the line that are going to change
the game forever and could potentially
make it one of the greatest competitive
experiences out there this is like what
I thought OverWatch 2 was going to be
this is like what I expected we finally
there a year later season 9 and loses
both progress big PS list better late
than
[Music]
ever all right before we get into it we
here at the score Esports have a second
merch drop let's have a look let's get
one thing straight you are the best
gamer on planet Earth and I
think it's time you started dressing the
part shift walking is for cowards smash
that W key and check out the score
esport drop to available now if you like
that and I know you did check the link
in the description below it's been a
long time coming but after the final
OverWatch league tournament here in
Toronto this past October teams are
finally starting to announce their
departure blizzard later confirmed in an
interview that they were in fact quote
transitioning from the OverWatch League
a few teams expressed their desire to
stay with the game but with blizzard
handing the keys off to thirdparty to's
the future is honestly looking quite
questionable so that's it then right
after little over a year OverWatch 2 is
finally dead just like everyone said it
would be actually no despite complaints
that the game was just an update touted
as a full new experience despite both
single player and the Esports components
being set on fire despite Blizzard's
best efforts to kill this game it's
actually doing pretty damn well listen
blizzard does not release their player
accounts so most of the numbers that you
find online are from third party
Aggregates but multiple sources have
reported that through season 7 the
monthly average has been over 25 million
players and roughly 1.7 million players
daily now once again I take all these
numbers with a massive grain of salt
because they could be widely different
depending on where you look but the
point is the game is far from being dead
and if we were to take the numbers at
face value is as consistent as many
other FPS titles right now the question
is how well to start off OverWatch is
currently going through its spooky
season and honestly the Halloween skins
always so that's probably brought a
lot of people back more importantly
OverWatch 2 has just experienced the
K-pop effect as in blizzard kind of sort
of ripped off League of Legends KDA by
taking a handful of the game's young
female Heroes and K-pop ifying them
equipped with a song and music video in
collaboration with real K-Pop group The
seraphim it may seem trivial to The
Outsiders but that prints money and
should probably be studied one day now I
know what you're thinking surely people
aren't just playing OverWatch right now
because it has Co cool skins can't be
that easy to which I respond yes yes it
can be but it's definitely not the only
reason people are coming back or
continuing to play you see OverWatch 2
is in a pretty damn good place right now
so much so that during my cheating break
from CS2 this has become my main game
and honestly being someone who is
currently frustrated with games like
valerant CS Apex and so on OverWatch has
the potential to become the top game if
these other games don't straighten their
out think about it it's been a year
of updates and meta changes with 5v5
plus new Heroes Maps modes reworks and
the game feels really good as a result
sure the game has its balance issues and
probably always will but nothing so
egregious that it takes me out of the
game next to that the cheating problem
is way less of an issue compared to
other titles there is a variety of game
modes you can play if you don't want to
do competitive and most importantly of
all the game actually has a clear future
yes the esport might be up in the air
but there's a lot more to Competitive
Gaming than watching sweaty kids play
for millions of dollars the most
important thing is to have an actual
good game with a solid road map of
content and when it comes to OverWatch 2
that's exactly what the dev showed us at
this most recent BlizzCon they are
committed to improving old Heroes and
maps with a complete rework to Road Hog
just dropping the other day three new
Heroes have already been announced mauga
the tank that is coming with the new
season in December another new support
and the first DPS hero since launch that
can apparently burrow into theing ground
the devs are also working on an entirely
new game mode that is taking the old 2cp
Maps like hanamura and finally
repurposing them and last but certainly
not least OverWatch 2 is getting a
complete overhaul and reworking to its
rank system no more playing Five matches
to see a change in your ELO your ELO
will update every single match win or
lose on top of that there's a new rank
new weapon rewards and similar to CS 2's
Premier system you are able to see
everyone's ELO and what's at stake
heading into a game making everything
extremely transparent we're removing the
requirement to get five wins or 15
losses to get a competive oh my God
bless bless we are
safe we're soing back like I said a game
doesn't need to have a massively
successful esport to be a great
competitive experience and with these
changes coming to OverWatch 2 I think
blizzard is trying to focus on doing
just that this past BlizzCon also marks
a bit of a philosophical change for the
company as well at least when it
pertains to OverWatch 2 you see before
blizzard shared a lot of similar
qualities with that of valve meaning
they didn't really communicate with the
audience never revealed anything and
carried themselves like their
didn't stink but now they're on stage
showing the world everything that's
coming down the pipe using player
feedback and at times even admitting
when they got certain things wrong and
because of that for the first time in
what feels like a very long time fans
are excited about the future of
OverWatch this is actually I'm really
excited for this actually because I feel
like this is going to bring back so many
players and
also I really want over there's no other
game like overwat like I said OverWatch
2 is by no means a perfect game but it's
a lot of fun right now and the road
ahead looks bright so bright that
compared to the current staleness of
valerant and whatever the CS2 is right
now this could be overwatch's chance to
truly take over the world of firstperson
Shooters so long as they don't screw it
up you know what I think is important is
having a good game and focusing on good
content good competitive atmosphere and
then the ort will come and even if it
doesn't who cares you know like like I
said a thousand times a game doesn't
need to have an ort to prove that it's
successful or a good game and I think
OverWatch is the perfect example of that
right now